the Matrix movies are so packed with
meaning that every line seems to carry
some deeper significance in that spirit
we're looking at some of the most
memorable lines from the Matrix films
that have way more meaning than anyone
realized
Neos first encounter with his primary
adversary Agent Smith arrives early in
the first matrix before Neos been clued
in to everything that's really going on
it's part of an interrogation in which
Smith freaks neo out with a variety of
threats including the seemingly simple
statement you're going to help us mr.
Henderson whether you want to what the
franchise hasn't yet established is that
even though it sounds like Smith is just
playing bad cop he's actually quite
correct at least in theory we later
learn in the Matrix Reloaded that Neos
status as the one is actually a piece of
programming it was implanted in him by
the architect as a part of a plan that
will allow the matrix to reboot and
preserve the appearance of choice among
the human race at this point in the
story neo is unknowingly a tool of the
machines and the matrix and he won't
figure that out until part 2 after neo
meets Morpheus and agrees to take the
red pill he awakens in his pod among the
human farm and has taken aboard Morpheus
ship as he learns the truth while on
board the Nebuchadnezzar he asked why
his eyes hurt the answer Morpheus
provides is simple and straightforward
you've never used them that explanation
is technically true because Neos
biological form has been locked up
inside that gel-filled pod for decades
but his question also offers some
interesting foreshadowing for the future
of his eyes the topic comes up again in
the Matrix Reloaded when the Merovingian
aware that neo can now see the matrix
this code asks you see
then in the Matrix Revolutions Agent
Smith
while in Bane's body blinds neo with an
electrical cable causing intense pain
but also giving him a new level of sight
his eyes are useless but he can still
see the energies around him as pure
light which he uses to make his final
journey to the machine city
after neo is woken up and pulled from
his pod he begins his training under
Morpheus and his crew this includes
sessions with tank who plugs neo into
his system and uploads a variety of
training programs into his brain
including skills and various martial
arts neil is immediately thrilled by
this process and he endures hours of
uploading at tanks hands when Morpheus
comes to check on him
tank says of neo 10 hours straight
a machine tank is of course simply
referring to Neos endurance as he
undergoes the strain of the uploading
process
hour after hour but he's also actually
weirdly close to the truth of Neos
actual identity though we don't learn
this until the Matrix Reloaded
meal is actually a tool of the machines
while not being a machine himself he was
designed to be an asset to them to help
in the rebooting of the matrix and the
further use of humanity as a docile
power source in a sense the machines
built neo encoded him for their own
purposes so in that sense tank is fully
correct
shortly after neo learns that the matrix
is nothing but a simulation he spends
some time contemplating his old life
which he thought was real but was
actually all in his head as he struggles
with coming to terms with that truth he
asks Trinity what it means that all his
memories never happened and that's when
she replies the matrix cannot tell you
who you are
Trinity's response is based on her
belief in the cause of freedom for
Humanity she wants to condition neo to
the new reality that he's living in
which will allow him to exercise his own
free will in ways he never could before
what's interesting though is that while
she turns out to be correct
the matrix does spend a good deal of
time in the course of the sequels trying
to tell neo who he is a large portion of
reloaded is devoted to characters like
the architect attempting to explain to
me oh that he was programmed to reboot
the matrix and that he is not unique
there have been other ones before and
there will be other ones after if fall
goes according to plan the matrix can
tell you who you are but neo must
overcome that
to achieve peace early in the matrix
kneel first meets the Oracle who tells
him matter-of-factly that he isn't the
one he eventually proves this statement
wrong by saving Morpheus and defeating
the agents at the end of the film when
he tries to protest that he can't be the
one because the Oracle said so Morpheus
explains that she told him exactly what
he needed to hear Neos sooner or later
you're going to realize just decided
there's a difference between knowing the
path neo spends much of the trilogy
struggling with this fact especially
since he's living in a world with
prophecies and an old woman who seems to
know his future he asks a lot of
questions in an effort to determine
exactly what he must do some people
including the architect attempt to lay
his path out for him very clearly in an
effort to manipulate him he tells him
that if he goes through the door that
allows him to save Trinity he will
effectively end the human race but neo
goes anyway he walks the path instead of
attempting to know it and finds a third
way that allows him to save both Trinity
and the future of Zion if I were you I
would hope that we don't meet again
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you